we asked you to vote for the 2017 movie
she wanted us to make an honest trailer
for and now your number one choice Wow
you guys clearly hate us after every
Transformers movie there is hope hope
that they won't make another one now the
BAE bots are back for his final chapter
until they return up to 14 more times
no transformers the last night strap in
for another Shakespearean tale in the
sense that it's a tale told by an idiot
full of sound and fury signifying
nothing but you can bet your life
there'll be some big-ass explosions
while to moderate racism hey chief
my name is Sherman it's okay to be a kid
little j.lo and action that looks like
to RadioShack's doing kama Sutra in a
hurricane
how we doing we don't yet nope still
going huh forget everything you knew
about the Transformers because so did
Michael Bay who in the third one said
Cybertron was destroyed and in this one
said actually it's back in the fourth
one said Megatron is now Galvatron and
then this one said nevermind
he's Megatron again and in the first one
said the Transformers came to earth to
find the Allspark and learn English from
the internet but in this one said you
know what good they were allies with
King Arthur and one of them killed
Hitler that's too much the killed Hitler
see we're not the only ones insulting
the intelligence of Transformers movie
fans so is he
because we live in the darkest timeline
prepare for another Transformers movie
that's mostly about the humans Cade
Yeager is back and he's still an
inventor I'm an inventor that's still
from Texas they have the support of the
entire world
now he'll team up with Vivienne Wembley
a brilliant British uterus have you
found a man yet it's risen you're always
single what generic military guys
yelling generic military things
raise it raise it nicely a random street
urchin so awkwardly crammed in even she
doesn't know why she's here
what are you doing here and Anthony
Hopkins who delivers a brief portrayal
of a man who won an Oscar and then
realized he's doing a Transformers movie
my own family he had something smallpox
Aldous
it's okay Sir Anthony at least shooting
in peed on by bumblebee the rage-fueled
violent Decepticons are back and the
only things that can stop them are the
rage-fueled violet Autobots I am killing
you
I'll burn you so bad you'll wish you
died as a job and their rage fueled
violent human allies no you want to
Facebook really hard caught in the
middle is Optimus Prime I am Optimus
Prime I am Optimus Prime we get it I am
Optimus Prime he's been forced by a lady
with dreads to turn against his family
and if you said that's the exact plot of
fate in the Furious congratulations you
saw some really bad movies in 2017
wander across a two-and-a-half hour run
time
it's Optimus good is he bad do I care or
does he go for half the movie why is
there kung-fu robot Butler am i high
what do words even mean anymore so roll
out with a franchise Michael Bay is so
bored with he's literally making
characters out of garbage
builds up the importance of bumblebees
voice only believed in the temp audio
from his sound engineer sting like a bee
and films the whole thing on three
different aspect ratios that he rapidly
shifts between for the entire movie god
I cannot unsee that now starring Jar Jar
clings silence of the grabs the boogie
night
Meghan foe will orphan angry drunk old
or Star Wars
and actual quotes from the film that
perfectly describe the Transformers
writers room logic has left the building
a Michael Bay set big personalities just
crashing in on Maddy
a Michael Bay script from you it sounds
an old vaguely racist Michael Bay's
answer to everything and us after
writing another honest trailer for yet
another Transformers movie as my life
will be wasted
have you ever felt like that sigh robot
you know what's almost as awkward is
that long scene about having sex with
Mark Wahlberg's underage daughter in the
last movie and even longer scene about
how long it's been since Mark Wahlberg
had sex no Whoopi must've gained it
spent well well how long's a while we
come on the year kids table and the
Oscar goes to the boss baby pretty neato
mosquito Batman is a badass and that's a
trailer an honest trailer
wowsa banana mauza